quand la salle est pleine et que la
lumière s'éteint le temps se suspend
tout d'un coup on attend tous que la
magie commence
[Musique]
sap a été retenue il faut juste que
quelqu'un me donne ma chance
dites vous n'avez pas besoin d'un
pianiste pas depuis trente ans
et voici notre chorégraphe jambes de
rêve
vous avez raté votre silhouette je n'ai
rien d'autre à voir
alors je vais leur faire bien
je veux passer une audition tu te
souviens que c'est un livreur
oui il nous faut une vedette la vedette
c'est la danse c'est un nom sur la fiche
qui fait venir les gens
kyle a signé le contrat elle reprend son
rôle dans free dax marleau j'ai besoin
que tu m'aides avec kyle et danseurs
d'ensemble non pas d'évolution carrière
ils ne sont jamais sur le devant de la
scène
j'ai besoin que le spectacle soit
flamboyant qui nous emporte tout du long
moi aussi elle est phénoménale
qu'est ce qui se passe exactement entre
un vendeur et toi elle s'est mise à nu
pour toi pendant la répétition
[Applaudissements]
tu es fort et tu as beaucoup de talent
montrez nous ce que tu vaux
[Musique]